okay big news this is the point in the
week and in the show where I mention
some interesting discussions from the
David Pakman show subreddit which you
can find at david pakman.com slash our
EDD IT the first thing i want to mention
from the subreddit is that the subreddit
itself has achieved more than ten
thousand subscribers and in fact it's
ten thousand ninety-eight as of this
exact moment when I am mentioning it yes
the subreddit has ten thousand
subscribers one of the biggest sub
reddits of independent progressive shows
and there's really great discussion
there there's a lot of topic suggested
for the show on the subreddit we have
now a full slate of moderators who
ensure that there is respectful debate
and we limit trolling and all of that
stuff so more than 10,000 of you are
participating please keep signing up
it's free and it's a really great place
to engage with other viewers of the show
and with the show staff etc etc david
pakman.com slash read it also there's a
very interesting post on the subreddit
we mentioned I believe it was last week
or the week before on audience questions
I was asked David why is your show
disproportionately male in terms of its
audience and I explained it's not just
our show it's all online news and
politics shows or this is something that
we contend with we have
disproportionately male audiences and a
post was made exploring ideas for
attracting more women viewers to the
show and they range from the wacky like
doing the show with no shirt on or
possibly poppin my collar or speaking
Spanish or there are also other sort of
more reasonable ideas that were
suggested including topic choice and
other things and yeah I mean I think
that this is actually it would be an
interesting nut to crack because both
from the point of view of I would love
to have more women in the audience
simply because I think that that would
in terms of the feedback that we get
provide more balanced feedback since the
since the audience is disproportionately
male the feedback that I get about the
show comes disproportionately from a
male audience even though half the
country is women so that would be
interesting for
and foremost and then secondly from an
advertising perspective we deal with a
lot of advertisers who don't want to
advertise because they say well your
audience you know we target women or we
at least need something closer to a
50-50 audience based on our demographic
research and our focus groups you're
mostly male audience is not a good fit
so I think financially it would also be
great for the show to attract more women
so for all reasons that's something that
I think we should strive to do and you
can comment on this by joining the
subreddit at david pakman.com slash read
it now let me also mention I have
something to give away I have a really
great card game to give away ok this is
a new sponsor that is doing some ads on
our show the game is called impeach the
card slap game it's a really fun game
it's great for parties I've played it
with some friends it's a combination of
really great humor about the Trump
administration and really great cartoon
artwork and it's also just a fun
well-designed game and I have 5 of these
to give away ok I have five i will send
these to you one of them not all five to
the first five people who emailed me
david at david pakman.com or use the
contact form on our website okay if you
don't email me in time it'll just be the
first come first serve we will send them
anywhere in the world
email me say I want one of the impeach
card games include your address include
all the information I need so that that
way we don't have to email back and get
engaged in this sort of endless loop of
emails okay but I've got five of those
to give away and if you don't get one of
the five you can go to david pakman.com
slash impeach and use the coupon code
Pakman to get 10% off the card game and
they've got a bunch of other funny Trump
satirical t-shirts and other stuff david
pakman.com slash impeach to get 10% off
with the coupon code Pakman but I've got
5 free impeach card games great for
parties especially if you've got
conservative friends coming over nice
little game to pull out instead of
playing you know any one of those other
games which I won't name because they
haven't advertised on the show